nice to meet you I'm Ruthie and today
I'm gonna be talking about biomaterials
as UI designing new user experiences so
for those of you in the back this is me
I wore the same dress so I you can see
me you can recognize me later a little
bit about me I live in New York City
that's my twitter handle if you're ever
in town or if you live in New York tweet
at me I'll buy you coffee and we'll hang
out I work as a software engineer at a
company called Warby Parker we were an
e-commerce company my colleague is over
there we sell we sell eyeglasses and
sunglasses and so I'm a software
engineer on the systems development team
there and so I work on things such as
software for logistics supply chain
Rachele retail operations customer
experience tools and I was thinking
about how the end result of all this
software that I'm working on is actually
this physical product my glasses
and so as curious and understanding how
people are extending programming today
to physical materials and so I started
to learn about this space and I got to
this field of biomaterials which are
materials that are either derived from
nature or synthetically produced based
on materials found in nature or some
kind of combination of the two and the
reason that they're an interesting type
of material to program is that they
already have forms of programming
happening within them through their
biological systems whether that's
feedback loops or repair mechanisms or
different life cycle events such as
reproduction and decomposition and so
people have been exploring ways to
extend those and to harness different
naturally-occurring attributes and
traits and these biological systems to a
program with these materials and the
reason I think that it's really
important and interesting to learn about
as software engineers is first of all
most of the interfaces that our users
interact with are not the ones through
which they experience ourself we're on
there's a lot of materials that people
touch and use everyday that we can
design new experiences for and as
software developers we we designed for
the capabilities of the interfaces that
we build for whether that's the haptic
quality or pedometer or
gyroscopes or camera of a smartphone or
the conversational user interfaces of an
Alexa or Google home or the form factor
of a VR headset so hopefully by learning
a little bit more about what's possible
you can start to imagine new types of
experiences you can build and extend to
different materials so so what if we
could create clothing that responded to
heat and humidity changes in our body by
opening up and helping our body return
to equilibrium and then closing the
flaps when we cool down researchers at
the MIT Media Lab mediated matter group
along with colleagues at the Royal
College of Art in London and Zhejiang
University in China asked themselves
this question and this would be quite
hard to do with traditional sensors and
mechanical and electrical engineering
making the fabric open up and close but
then they found that this actually
happens a lot in different biological
systems they honed in on this soybean
that has when it's fermented it has this
bacteria called bacillus su Billis that
basically changes its form in reaction
to environmental changes and so
basically nature is full of all kinds of
sensors and actuators things that
trigger motion and so they're able to
utilize that and to utilize a new type
of and a material engineering called bio
printing to create films they then put
on these fabrics and we're able to make
them respond to changes in the body so I
can show you what that looks like on a
closer scale here you can kind of see
the biofilms and then this is a zoomed
in picture of the bacteria that they
utilized and this is a picture of the
bio printer that they use to print these
films and this is them growing some
bacteria in a lab so some of the
advantages of using a living system as a
sensor and actuator are it's safe
there's no wires it's edible
it reproduces easily and you can use
that as another design element and also
it it's a sorry
it's you can use you can use the
reproductions a design element at the
same time they're also some challenges
for any of you who've done biology
experiments you know that sometimes you
put the same inputs and you get
different kinds of outputs and so trying
to make the results of their production
of the bacteria in the lab get the same
result each time has been challenging
for them beyond that they also have been
trying to play around with their ability
to configure exactly the reaction that
the fabric has in response to heat and
humidity changes so those are some
challenges but um it demonstrates this
opportunity to bring together new types
of engineering and things that we
observe in biology to create new kinds
of fabrics and new kinds of wearables
that would be hard to do just using one
of those systems this is mushroom root
otherwise known as mycelium it's
incredibly versatile material and it's
found all around us um it's fall now
it's almost October and so like all
around us every time a leaf falls and
falls onto the ground mushroom root
decomposes it and forms it back into
soil so it's this very available process
around us and we know that we can shape
the inputs that we put into the
decomposition that happens with mushroom
root and get very different kinds of
outputs everything from something as
light as foam to as durable and hard as
concrete actually beats concrete and
tests that compare the two I'm just
something as pliable as leather we can
utilize mushroom roots in their
decomposition process to create this by
playing around at the inputs and things
such as the nutrition and environment in
which they're decomposing materials and
so on and what's really exciting about
this too is it can offer this
closed-loop waste processing ecosystem
where we can feed waste to the mushroom
roots and it can break it down and
produce these new kinds of materials we
can use rather than having to produce
them separately and create new types of
waste as a byproduct so I'll tell you a
little bit of how people are using this
this is from a company called eco votive
they're trying to reinvent plastics by
using mushroom root and
their CEO talks a lot about how it's
very easy today to get things shipped in
two days or same day and we have a lot
more things being shipped to our homes
and to our offices etc and you can
return that easily no problem it's
usually free but the styrofoam that
comes with your packaging takes ten
thousand years to decompose and so
they're hoping that by using mushroom
route and by putting it as kind of an
intermediary in agricultural waste
systems they can create this sustainable
type of plastic going forward they also
make bricks and they collaborated with
this architecture firm based in New York
called the living which made this
40-foot structure made of 10,000 living
bricks and they were exploring ways that
we can use mushrooms for building
materials they also tested the bricks
against like extreme wind extreme heat
rain etc and they held up very well and
also one of the interesting properties
of mushroom root is it binds to other
materials very easily and you can also
form it into whatever shape you want and
so this offers an interesting
opportunity for a construction going
forward and so here's another picture of
the tower they built let's see here's
another picture and you can kind of see
what the bricks look like this is from a
company called micro works they're
exploring creating weather out of
mushroom root and kind of changing the
supply chain of leather to come from
mushrooms last thing I wanted to talk
about is this company called my Kotex
there they're inspired by soft body
systems which grow in a modular way and
basically what they've been trying to do
is create these modular parts of a
textile by changing the inputs they give
to the mushroom decomposition process
and so like things like a collar or
sleeves ruffles or buttons are produced
in different ways and then they put that
together and form an entire textile so
you can kind of see how they're growing
some of those materials in the lab here
and so what's interesting here is just
our ability to utilize this natural Dee
composition process to create new kinds
of materials so another a group of
researchers that's looking at how we can
use naturally-occurring process and by
processes and biological systems to
create new types of structures is this
research group led by someone named Neri
Oxman at MIT Media labs mediated matter
group and so basically they were
exploring ways that we can play around
with what shapes the ways silkworms spin
their cocoons and how we can learn from
them and then utilize those as design
elements that couldn't create very
different kinds of structures so you can
kind of see some silk runs spinning
structure there and then this is the
full structure they ended up creating
and so basically they learned from the
slope worms that things such as the
light they were exposed to silkworms
have a guide thread and so things like
the thickness of this thread or its
orientation all shape the type of silk
that's produced and like thinness and
thickness and other qualities around it
and so they were able to take that and
then use a cad and use different
programs to UM design the structure they
wanted to create they created 26
polygonal panels with different guide
threads and they set 6,500 silkworms
loose on it and then over the course of
a few weeks they created this structure
and what's cool is actually the Silk
Road is naturally deprecated by laying
eggs and becoming Moss and flying away
and so so and then the eggs they lay can
either help reinforce the structure they
can create up to I think 250 additional
structures like this and so so yeah they
learn from the silk rooms and they took
those inputs they design a structure
they want to create and then they put
the silk music back on it and let them
create this structure and you can see
here another picture of how they're
creating it and so what's really
interesting here is this is something
that would actually be quite hard for a
traditional 3d printer to do to create
something that's so multi modal in such
different types of textures across an
entire structure and also even just to
print something this large but it's
actually something that's quite easy for
silkworms to do
and so so they're exploring ways that we
can expand our toolset that we use for
architecture and design to include
living systems besides that they're also
able they were explored ways that you
can use silkworms and the type of output
they're producing as a way to learn
about the input like to learn about the
materials they're being guided by and
they're exploring uses of this in
architecture fashion and also one that
I'm really excited about which is
disaster recovery and relief efforts
like think about what if we could create
these pseudo structures and let
silcoon's create shelters for people so
there's a lot of interesting ways that
they're exploring utilizing this for
design and architecture creating new
materials of the future here's another
picture another group that's looking at
how we can look at the materials
available to us to help us solve
problems that we would otherwise have to
create materials in a lab to do is this
group led by a researcher named and
rappelling at the University of Ottawa
he has this interdisciplinary group of
material scientists stem cell biologists
physicists software engineers artists
and they all come together and try to
think about what speculative augmented
biology systems of the future might look
like and one of the areas they focus on
is regenerative medicine and so
basically regenerative medicine is this
really exciting opportunity for us that
as our bodies break down and our organs
fail we'll be able to grow organs in a
lab that'll either help repair our body
or we can replace organs in our body
that are breaking down with these ones
we're growing in a lab and the ways that
people are currently doing this are one
either donated organs I don't know how
many of you are organ donors I'm one but
people are taking those donated organs
and either if that's the organ that
someone needs they're putting that in
someone's body or if it's not the order
that they need they do something called
D cellular is a ssin where they
basically remove all the living cells in
this underlying polymer matrix is that
naturally occurs in the organ is present
and then they put stem cells in it and
they let the organ that they'd like to
generate grow in that matrix and that is
successful and then besides use
donated organs to do that people have
also created this material in a lab and
so they grow organs on that but both of
those are kind of expensive approaches
and so and rappelling and his team they
were wondering like nature provides us
this almost endless variety of
architectures and shapes and structures
and maybe we could find something that
kind of mimics what were producing in a
lab that's already available to us in
nature and so they did and they found
apples so and repelling wife is actually
a puppet maker so she's very good at
carving wood and so basically what you
see here is she's carved this ear shape
in apples and then they do cellular eyes
the apples they put stem cells in it and
they were able to successfully penetrate
the scaffolding and grow into organs
that you could then integrate with
living systems including Mouse mice and
humans and and they're very inspired by
open source and so they made sure when
they were decellularized in the apples
to only use available materials easily
available on traders like dish soap they
also created this open-source DIY
incubator that is inspired by Andrew
pilings dumpster diving and so this is
what you need to put the organs in to
let them grow and so so yeah so I wanted
to mention that I have soybeans mushroom
roots and apples as giveaways for after
the talk and I have instructions on how
you can do cellular eyes the Apple and
grow organs in it as well as how you can
ferment the soybeans and how you can use
mushroom root to create new structures
as well so I'll have that at the end but
I'm so beyond this Apple project and
Rapala Ghana's lab are really interested
in how we can look at the ways that
cells adapt to environments that they
weren't they didn't evolve to succeed in
and are still able to succeed in those
and how we can push that to the limit
and explore new kinds of biology and
engineering with that and and how you
can do genetic engineering without
actually modifying DNA but just by
understanding how you couldn't bring
different biological systems together
and help them integrate so one of the
next projects they're working on is
asparagus asparagus looks kind of like
what we're trying to do with
of Medicine when creating spinal cords
and also blood vessels so they're
exploring that as a new type of tool for
regenerative medicine another set of
companies it's exploring and researchers
who are exploring ways we can take this
type of technology such as D cellular is
a ssin and specifically use our body to
create new parts of our body outside of
our body to put back in our body or also
to use our body to create new types of
organs that we can then test out
medicine and drugs that we'll put in our
body are this group of companies
including epip own Terra bio systems
pepra gen and emulate so I'll talk about
epi bone first so they're exploring how
you grow human organs outside the body
they started with bone because even
though it has a complex shape it's a
single cell type so it's kind of a good
test case and they were like we can
solve the shape issue through 3d
printing etcetera and so what they do is
now when you have a bone defect they
take a scan of your defect and then they
take multipotent stem cells from your
fat cells which can grow into a lot of
different types of organs and then they
create an incubator or that allows the
bone to grow exactly in the shape of the
defect you have and within about six
weeks bone tissue starts to form and so
I you can see another picture of how
they're doing that here and there and
beyond being a test case for exploring
how we can grow organs outside the body
using the body it's also it solves a
specific problem it takes it's
recovering when you have a bone defect
and you're putting a new bone can be
hard for a few reasons first of all your
body might reject it second it might not
be exactly the shape that you need and
so fusing that together with your bone
might be challenging and then also you
might introduce diseases or other things
from a bone donor so that's a big bone
another example of bone this is a
lung-on-a-chip this is made by a company
named emulate so emulate along with
Pepperidge in which is trying to grow
liver tissue outside the body and
tarah Biosystems are just trying to grow
mini hearts outside the body what
they're trying to do is help to push
forward personalized medicine and drug
development by mimicking the way your
body is producing organs in development
or in healing and testing the way you'll
respond to drugs by creating these
isolated test environments and yes so
it's kind of this interesting concept
around how we can bring together our
understanding of how the body works new
types of technology and engineering to
push personalization forward another
company that's trying to grow mammal
tissue in a lab is modern meadows this
they're trying to be the first lab grown
leather company so you can see some of
their leather there initially they were
trying to grow cow cells in a lab but
this proved challenging for a few
reasons so they were trying to actually
just grow cow skin instead of growing
the entire cow just to produce leather
but this proved challenging because it
required this nutrient-rich medium they
had to have fetal bovine serum to give
it that new those nutrients and because
it was a nutrient rich medium their
samples kept getting contaminated by
things such as yeast so they were like
what if we can reframe the problem and
instead of trying to keep out the yeast
from our samples or samples can actually
just be yeast so the engineer used to
produce collagen which is the thing in
skin that gives it the stretchiness and
strength and yeah and then they were
able to utilize a lot of the things that
we have to produce yeast at industrial
scale relatively cheaply through
industries such as beer or even insulin
production which comes from yeast so you
can see an example of their samples here
and also by engineering leather in a lab
they were able to have a lot more
control over the leather that's produced
than they would have if it was it just
came from a cow they could play around
at the thickness or thinness of the
material its stretchiness etc and kind
of use those as design elements and
beyond that they also weren't limited by
things such as the size of the cow they
could bruise you they can produce these
really large sheets of leather so just
another picture this is their lab some
equipment they use this is what the
leather looks like kind of
in the middle of the process and this is
what it looks like when it's secured it
basically looks like leather and
actually starting tomorrow they'll have
their first sample on display a shirt at
the Museum of Modern Art in New York so
if you're in New York tweet at me I'll
buy you coffee and then we can go check
out these shirts another material that
we've known for a while that has these
really powerful properties but we
haven't really been able to grow at
scale and utilize those until recently a
spider silk which is actually just the
silk found in a spider web so I feel
like when you describe spider so that
kind of feels like you're describing
Superman it's stronger than steel
tougher than Kevlar more flexible than
nylon
it can expand up to 40% beyond its
original length and we've known about
these things for a while but we haven't
really been able to produce it at a
scale where it's been able to be
impactful in industries such as medicine
architecture or even creating more
absorbent bumpers for cars until
recently so people have tried to grow
spider silk at scale in different ways
they tried to grow these industrial
spider farms but at some point they
didn't really like the ecosystem didn't
support itself and basically spiders
started to eat one another then then
people tried to engineer goats to
produce milk that would create spider
silk and that sort of worked but it
ended up being kind of an expensive way
to produce spider silk so then they turn
to yeast different research groups and
so I'll talk about a few ways that
people are utilizing used to produce
spider silk so this is from a company
called spy BER based in Japan they
engineer bacteria to produce fibro and
that's the protein that gives spider
silk its properties and so and then they
spin on the output of they spin the
output the bacteria generate interest
oil can see you can kind of see what
that looks like here they're able to
they're able to actually engineer a lot
of kinds of silk that didn't that don't
exist in nature because of their level
of configurability around designing
the bacteria that's producing the silt
so they're able to like optimize for
strength or other qualities that they'd
like to explore and so they've been able
to create 250 different types of silk
and they they also are able to produce a
new type of silk within 10 days so
that's pretty exciting
here's a shirt they made a dress and
then this is the moon Parker they made
in collaboration with North Face this is
from a company called bolt threads based
in San Francisco they're also exploring
growing spider silk in a lab they I
think they ferment corn with genetically
engineered yeast and the output is a
this kind of spider silk material um and
so they've created up to 2,000 created I
think over 2,000 types of new fabrics as
a result of this process the last
example I wanted to talk about with
spider silk is a this project from
students at the University of
Pennsylvania a spider spider web beyond
filter keeping beyond holding prey also
filters out air pollutants and so they
created this living air pollutant that
someone can wear and a spider is weaving
its web and you know protecting the wear
last thing I wanted to talk about I'm
related to this concept of scale is data
storage and DNA so we have a big data
storage problem and we're continually
producing more data and we know that DNA
is actually the most efficient form of
data storage that we've ever seen it's
able to store up to 250 petabytes of
data in a single gram and so researchers
have been exploring ways that we can
utilize DNA to store data and obviously
it's going to be with us for a while DNA
and it's quite versatile and so in 2012
the first group of researchers were able
to store data in DNA I'm a group of
geneticists at Harvard a guy named
George church and his colleagues shriek
Assyrians a research team around that
and actually stored this book by the
researcher George Church in DNA but the
method they used was pretty inefficient
and didn't
utilized the full limit of what were
able to store in DNA some more recently
researchers at Columbia University
devised this algorithm called DNA
fountain where they basically they took
a computer operating system a computer
virus a film from the 1800s and a
information theory study by Claude
Shannon and they put it into one file
and they converted it to binary and then
broke it up into different binary
strings and randomly split those up into
droplets and added these tags to help
recombine it and then they sent it out
to a company called twist Biosystems
which I have a picture of here and I
think two weeks later they got back this
speck of DNA with their data and the big
advance there was that they didn't
actually have any errors when they
recombine the data so that was a big
step forward I'm still data storage is
quite in DNA is quite expensive and
people are hopeful that Microsoft whose
recently recently operationalized a goal
of using data storage in DNA by 2020
somewhere in their organization will
help push the cost down last interesting
thing about that is we're exploring ways
to lower the cost and increase the speed
of the ways we read and write to DNA and
so we're trying to produce DNA in a lab
using the same enzymes that we're
producing it using to produce it in our
bodies so um so all of these offer
interesting ways of thinking about how
we can expand programming today
oh hello okay
all of these offer new ways to think
about how we can extend programming
today to include different materials
around us and so when I was trying to
understand the reason this is so
important is because so many of the
materials that people interact with are
not the ones that we end up building for
so when I was trying to understand this
concept around how we can extend the
interface as we build for I got to this
field of ubiquitous computing which goes
back 30 years ago in 1991 Mark Weiser
who was then the CTO of Xerox PARC
published his vision for ubiquitous
computing which is this idea that
computing shouldn't be something that
takes us away from our environment
but it should become part of our
environment heroes are the best
technologies are those that disappear
they ambiently become part of our
environment till we fail we don't see
them rather than something that takes us
away from the spaces that we're living
in and he also wrote that there's more
information available at our fingertips
during the walk in the woods then when
we're using our computers but one
connects us to our environment one takes
us away from it so when we think about
biological systems and how we can
utilize the different cycles and
feedback loops and different attributes
that occur in them to extend programming
I think that this can help orient us so
in sum we can extend programming
interfaces to include materials by
bringing together biology and new types
of engineering and we can we can we can
already develop for the broad range of
interfaces that people interact with and
you know even the Internet of Things
which is trying to bring computing to
materials around us it's still trying to
put computers on things rather than
reimagining things as computers and so
we can try to broaden our perspective of
what a computer is and where we can do
computing to incorporate a much wider
range of materials and so knowing what
we know about what's possible I want to
know what experiences you want to design
today with these materials and I thought
we could end with a moment of
self-reflection so think about the shirt
and pants you're wearing or dress the
chair you're sitting on the bag you're
carrying and just the materials you've
interacted with today what information
do they have about you and your
surroundings how can we extend the
experiences we designed for to include
those materials so with that I would
love to answer any questions or talk
more about this topic like I said I have
some materials here you can get started
with programming and if you go to this
bitly link you can find some resources
for how to get started as well as my
presentation and speaker notes thank you
you